let's jump into the first big news here
from the post-millennial Louisiana rep
says Biden is staging Civil War by
pulling down Texas border barriers Texas
should stand their ground Higgins posted
this of course is is in response to
breaking news that the Supreme Court
will allow federal agents to cut Razer
wire Texas installed on us Mexico border
it was a 5 to four ruling leaving many
people shocked Texas is being
overwhelmed there's a story I don't know
if it's true but I'm hearing uh uh Mayor
Johnson in Chicago is having panic
attacks or is that true did you hear
that go check Google search see if you
can find that because I heard people
talking about on Twitter but we know
that the mayor's the mayor of Chicago
New York they are freaking out over the
massive influx of illegal immigrants On
the Border we know it is the worst we
have seen at least in my lifetime and
it's substantially worse than anything
we've seen in the past decade and so you
have Texas desperately trying to stop it
deploying armed soldiers of the Texas
National Guard to block federal agents
from being able to control the
jurisdiction in this area and now the
Supreme Court has ruled in favor of
federal agents this to me looks like a
Fort Sumpter esque type scenario where
the federal government is asserting
jurisdiction over an area the state is
rejecting it the state has deployed
armed n armed soldiers and the FEDS are
now countering we're hearing a lot of
crazy rumors but this does feel like uh
uh it could be escalating to this
Federal versus State conflict and with
as many states as we've seen who are
upset over the massive influx of illegal
immigration and the fact the Biden
Administration is facilitating this I
think I think we're walking on on on the
razor's edge here uh all I can see is
that the federal government is
intentionally letting immigrants in to
later repatriate or patriate them I
guess give them citizenship to go fight
in a war that they're anticipating I
don't understand other than that to
shift the census data right it's to say
there are this many people here and
that's why we should get extra
representation in the government even
though they're not here to legally vote
they didn't enter this country legally I
mean the implications of illegal
immigration are really serious and I
think uh the federal government is
actually pushing Texas to more seriously
consider secession they have that vote
coming up to consider it uh in November
I think they're going to isolate
themselves from what is ultimately a
small country that we're all attached to
I mean Texas is independently
economically viable without the US the
look it is the policy of the Biden
Administration have open borders period
Joe Biden himself blurted it out three
days ago he said when they asked him
point blank is the border secure he said
no and I've said that for a number of
years well he needs to tell that to
secretary mayorcas plus Jean Miss Jean
Pierre because that's the exact opposite
of what they have said notice what the
mayor of Chicago said he said this is
not sustainable we're going to run out
of money soon because we don't have the
money for the Social Services for this
influx of migrants and the answer is to
give them citizenship H how is that the
answer uh when when secretary blinkin uh
met with the president of Mexico in
their joint communication okay he also
implied that the answer was somehow to
give this influx of Migrant citizenships
well we understand that would allow them
to vote perhaps that's the goal but I
don't see how that will solve the the
fiscal uh problem the the the fentol
problem the crime problem the fact that
these cities these counties these States
they're running out of money they don't
have the money to sustain this influx of
of migrants I think the money they're
looking for is to facilitate more of it
we've seen for years they've been
putting under
they've been smuggling children on
planes and and transporting them across
the country mhm so we we've you know
it's funny when we have a Democrat come
in here and we show like Marin
Williamson we show her the story it's
like this from 2021 where undercover
video catches them doing this they're
smuggling people they're getting away
with it the thing about just getting
them into vote which they might be doing
to make give them citizenship and let
them vote is like they could just use
electronic voting machines and flip
tallies and like cheat the voting
systems if they really wanted to
guarantee a vote outcome they don't need
to destroy the system within within
immigrants so I don't understand there's
got to be more than it's a long-term
solution as opposed to a short-term if
they were to flip votes that's shortterm
if you're to bring in people promise
them public coffers n offer them
executive order citizenship or something
which I think Biden will probably try to
do at the end of the year I think there
a strong probability of it then you will
get a longer term voting base but it's
more it's more than that it's that
putting these people into cities
increases democratic Democratic members
of Congress so if these people go there
the next time we have a Census count
which is I think what it's going to be
six years correct no six years how many
how many seats will the Democrats get
from non-citizens regardless of whether
these people vote and how many Electoral
College votes will they get regardless
of if these people vote the idea is to
just change the basic makeup of the
American electorate look my my sister's
son my nephew her only son uh who lives
here in West Virginia died of a fental
overdose late last week 38 years old
this has touched my family
directly it it's a horrific tragedy uh
but but that's what these policies are
giving us and this Administration
doesn't seem to care in fact they seem
to be promulgating it I think it's just
you know it feels like the unraveling of
the country intentionally like a if we
can't have it then we will burn it down
if we can't have it no one can kind of
thing like a deranged uh stalker
ex-lover who's up set that his
girlfriend moved on so he's like if I
can't have her no one can they're just
they're just destroying everything cuz
they're mad Trump's going to win or
perhaps more pragmatically they are
concerned that Donald Trump will win and
they will go to prison so they want to
destroy whatever they can to make sure
they weaken the machine which will once
once Trump is elected will be turned
against them did maybe I mean the other
thing is that they didn't maybe they
never valued the country before right
they never valued America at any point
and so the idea that they're like we
don't care that this is destroying
anything because we never thought it was
worth protecting or saving they can't
see why America is a unique nation and
why importing fentol into poor parts of
the US is a disaster right there's sort
of an elitism about it that says this is
not something I I care about because it
doesn't touch my life and in fact I
don't value this I mean it was always
what celebrities who like if Donald
Trump gets elected I'm moving to Canada
it's the same type of mentality I can
leave this behind even if you die from
him but you even have liberals like Eric
Adams the mayor of New York City who
runs for mayor saying he's proud that
New York is a sanctuary City today he's
saying this threatens to destroy New
York As We Know It uh these Mayors they
don't know what to do they can't they
can't provide the social services
required uh and people who are legal
residents are being denied social
services so we can house uh uh you know
migrants now here's my concern you
already have armed National Guard armed
soldiers deployed to block federal
agents the Supreme Court has now ruled
in favor of these federal agents they
can go in and remove Razer wire
basically allowing wave after wave of
Criminal Alien entering this to enter
this country the Texas National Guard is
already defying the feds the feds have
asserted jurisdiction here Texas
National Guard said screw off what's
going to
change why would the Supreme Court
saying you can remove the razor wire
change anything about Texas state law
and how they handle law enforcement
Texas has said it is illegal to to cross
our borders in this way and we will
enforce the law the feds are saying we
can remove this and allow them to break
the law I don't I don't see Texas
backing down from this Texas is going to
say that's great Supreme Court really
really great good luck removing the
razor wire when our guys are standing
there holding guns blocking you from
access to the river what's what are the
feds going to do show up with guns and
point the guns at the National Guard and
say get out of the way is the is is
Texas I mean fair fair question is Texas
going to instruct their armed soldiers
you must now evacuate and let the feds
come in because it's the order is uh
it's a temporary order pending the the
ongoing litigation is there a chance
that like effectively Texas could be
held in contempt of court like what are
the punishments for not going along with
this temporary order pending ongoing
liation what does that even mean when
the feds have already asserted
jurisdiction on on the river and Texas
said f off you you you can file all the
paperwork in the world for injunction
the feds have already asserted it's our
jurisdiction and tax said don't care get
out with guns so the only option now is
either the the only paths forward would
be Texas backs down and says we hereby
respect the Supreme Court we are going
to remove all of our law enforcement we
are going to allow wave after wave of
criminal aliens to break state law and
do nothing about it or they're going to
say this changes nothing it's illegal in
our state we don't care if if if the
feds think otherwise I mean that's what
Paxton said attorney general Ken Paxton
said you know this is this is a
temporary order and the litigation is
ongoing and we're going to continue to
fight this I mean he's not saying
exactly what they'll do if they'll
refuse to let them take the razor wire
out but he is saying that Texas is not
willing to put up with this sort of uh
Federal reach their border security so
what are the feds going to do
next uh nothing this this is a classic
struggle between Federal power and
State's rights uh but while we're
sitting here trying to sort this out how
many million more people are going to
come into the country illegally and my
fear is that let's say Donald Trump wins
in November hand
Joe Biden rubber stamps an executive
order granting a quick path of
citizenship for all of these people
Millions at that point would be what 12
to 15 million people and then there's
instant instantly people say we're suing
we're going to challenge this and he
smiles and says yeah in two years when
this is resolved those people will have
already gotten their papers good luck
resolving it I think we need to set some
precedent about how awful uh horrendous
unethical illegal that would be for a
president to by decree give people
citizensh you mean like Daka yeah some
Mass swipe of the pen and you mean like
it's already been done like Obama did
with the dream with dreamers if it's
been done before yeah this kind of thing
cannot we can't let that stand that's
insane that would be insane and now
imagine this scenario Joe Biden let's
say it's November 25th Trump is
president-elect Joe Biden rubber STS an
executive order saying we're going to
secure the Border but the compromise
will be all the people who are here are
granted a standard path to citizenship
which will take three to five months you
mail in your form it's mailed back you
sign it you send it back in you're a
citizen you'll get your
paperwork and then come next year it's
challenged in the courts finally makes
it to scotus scotus says
unconstitutional and moves to revoke
citizenship from 15 million people who
are previously illegal immigrants Donald
Trump as President says we are going
going to remove these people who enter
this country illegally and were only
granted citizenship under false
pretenses the left then says look at all
the videos of trump rounding up American
citizens and putting them in
camps D Eisenhower deported 1.3 million
illegals it it can theoretically be done
uh and as you have a deteriorating conu
condition in the country in terms of
crimes drugs Economic Opportunity and so
on uh I I'm not sure that the Democrats
would be on the popular side of this
also I'm not sure the constitutionality
of Joe Biden waving a wand and saying
well you're a US citizen I'm not sure
you can do that what about
Daka look I'm not a lawyer so I'm not
I'm not I don't think it's legal but I
mean
Obama executive order was what do what
does Daka stand for can you look it up
stand for um deferred action on right
right child childhood arrivals right and
so This Is How They inch
forward uh uh they say okay well you
know if you were here as a kid it's not
your fault so we're we're going to give
you a path to citizenship and there's a
lot of people who only know America they
don't know any other country and so then
what happens is people on the right
compromise a lot of conservatives don't
but many on the right will be like okay
fine fine we'll stop there though the
next step is Joe Biden's going to say
it's been a crisis it's been a disaster
but the amount of money that's going to
cost for Mass deportations are beyond
our capabilities the best thing we can
do is document these people and then
secure the border and you'll end up
getting a bunch of Middle Road people
being like okay fair just like when
Reagan said he wanted he wanted amnesty
and the compromise was we secure the
Border but we Grant amnesty my fear is
let let let let me let me go back a
little back a little bit back in time
this is what I've been saying is going
to happen with Texas I said if Texas is
overwhelmed by this wave of immigration
eventually the state legal apparatus is
going to assert their jurisdiction and
say we're going to do something about
this what did we see state of course
passed the law saying Crossing's illegal
the feds said screw off we saw the feds
trying to remove the B the barriers and
the water and the razor wire and I said
if the feds keep doing this with Texas
saying no eventually Texas will assert
its jurisdiction and push back on the
feds then Texas did this with armed
soldiers my fear is how this escalates
and so many have made the point that if
Donald Trump moves for Mass deportation
of 15 million people when he gets
elected the left will post photos and
videos of trains and buses and camps and
claim Trump is Hitler now imagine if
it's substantially worse and many of
these people are granted rubber stamped
citizenship by a Joe Biden executive
order
unconstitutionally that doesn't matter
to the Democrat activists and and
lawfare activists they will just
publicly say look what is what does
okazi Cortez say all the time legal ases
refugees they're lying these are
economic migrants fighting age males who
are coming here by themselves VES or
smuggling children and then the the
media and the Democrats lie and claim
they're refugees so what happens next
year when Donald Trump is President and
the Democrats just lie and say these are
people who are being naturalized these
are citizens Trump is targeting citizens
and they're going to call it racist he's
saying he's targeting you know Latin
American citizens and they're going to
use their rubber stamp unconstitutional
garbage to try and justify in the Press
yeah I think I mean I think the Optics
would be really bad either way and sort
of something I hope Republicans are
thinking about going into the end of
2024 early 2025 I mean you asked me when
the show started to look up if how uh
Mayor Johnson of Chicago is doing and
the first thing when I looked up his
remarks are uh he's arguing that
Governor abot is intentionally attacking
leaders of color by busting migrants to
the cities I mean it's going to be an
ugly and divisive fight between these
two sides the post millennial did report
it that uh allegedly there's a reporter
who made the claim Mayor Johnson has
suffered multiple panic attacks
at around you know as immigration is
bubbling up and that's the insinuation
for the record on DACA uh it didn't give
anyone citizenship it it give two years
stay on deportation for children that
didn't have uh like felonies or whatever
and then what happened um then they
tried to propose the DREAM Act which
would have given citizenship but that
did not pass it would be highly
irregular for um a dictator to decide
who is and is not a citizen of the
country without legal recourse and
there's a lot of things that Joe Biden
has done which would be highly irregular
and dictatorial I do love the the meme
of they've arrested their political
Rivals they're trying to put the lead
candidate uh opposing the regime into
prison all while screaming the other
side are fascists yeah the people who
are trying to censor and cancer people
the people who are who are conducting
you 178,000 illegal surveillances on
American citizens uh without warrant uh
the what the folks who are trying to
lock up Donald Trump they're they say
we're the danger to democracy really
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net